congratulations on everything and
everybody is saying it puts a little
pressure on you but they're like she's
the front-runner she's got it dad no
one's supposed to know that they all
seem to think they know well I think of
people I mean great but but oh who know
I mean have you seen my category it is
stacked and I would happily and
honorably lose to every single woman in
this category I I can't believe our
names are being spoken in the same
sentence everybody said you're not gonna
lose so therefore I'm gonna go ahead and
ask you how you gonna celebrate
we're going to an Amazon party later and
then in and out Bert that's a good
celebration price doing like animal
style the fries absolutely animal burger
animal fries maybe a shake or something
you're living it up I'm gonna live this
dress lose lip lip lip the dress is
gorgeous how did you decide on this
dress um well it showed it Fashion Week
just this last week or so and right out
the runway yes exactly and it I loved it
the minute I put it on my body I felt
like a princess I love the color and I
love Oscar de la Renta it was gorgeous
you're the jewelry Thank You Tiffany
thank you congratulations and everything
they're telling me I gotta wrap it up
over here so but I'm gonna say it
congratulations at a time is everybody
saying you're gonna win Oh a thank you
very much pressure none at all
[Music]